are you just gonna burn down your career
and take me with you coin flip get out
of here
what's on your mind today like I want to
change but I'm not particularly open to
make those changes I'm trying every time
I get rid of one compulsion another
compulsion comes up are you yawning
Right Now spoiler alert I feel like I'm
stuck
right
how does that make you feel
that way
Jimmy Liz hey it's three in the morning
I'm sorry what's in that bowl pretzels
the other Bowl maybe some painkillers
maybe there's painkillers in there yeah
I have to ask is this you forever
[Music]
hey Paul I'm worried about you kid I
mean grieving here
you've been numbing
stop you're doing sad face this is just
face
I have resting dead wife face
he just kept on going on and on about
how dumb I am but he loves me
your husband is emotionally abusive he's
not working on it he doesn't intend to
just leave him
okay
I think I can help people if I get my
hands a little bit dirtier your mom
wanted you to scatter her ashes right we
know what they should do don't you ever
want to just shake them well we don't
shake them I take that back run huh it
sounds so unethical just gonna burn down
your career and take me with you
coin flip get out of here
right this is my office it took you
longer than it should have my patients
are really thriving this thing I'm doing
is really working I'm right behind you
nobody gets through this life unscathed
I can't remember mom's laugh I can feel
her slipping away
face with a choice you're gonna let your
grief drown you or are you going to face
it come through the other side
spark back
just gonna leave your car here I'm a
white guy in Pasadena the cops will
probably just take it back to my house
for me must be nice
Derek how's it going just walking the
dog I didn't want my patient moved into
her sister's house sounds like the day's
off to a great start for both of us
[Music]